alter das schild stand da vorhin noch
nicht was ist los mit diesem projekt und
da steht einfach so ein fucking tnt vor
meiner tür und jetzt kommen wir pfeile
untergeschossen was ist los
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft leben
ich bin ich habe gerade fall schaden
bekommen die wache angekommen
ich wollte euch einfach eine weitere
folge im angriff leben bringen weil ich
das schon sehr lange nicht mehr
hochgeladen habe und ich bin gerade das
erste mal wieder auf dem server und sehe
gerade dass die handwerks gilde
irgendwer fertig gebaut hat ich weiß
nicht wie bei wem schönes gebäude wäre
schade wenn es brennen würde
wer ist denn plötzlich sinnlos mit den
leuten wie sony dann also hetzerisch
hier richten jd leiden pid würde ich bau
mir das schild hier einfach ab das kann
er nicht sein dass hier einfach so leute
mich die handwerks gilde so so ok bauen
wir auch mal ab was haben die denn hier
alle die steht ein schild du wirst
leiden tod etwas wie sie wollen mich
alle tot sehen er ist was soll das denn
steht drin auch noch irgendwas hier ist
nichts wie komisch ist das denn also ich
hab auch wenig bau dieser kiste heilige
arme lohkirchen armin oh ich liebe euch
ich liebe euch hab mich ich habe mich
diamant schwer mit schärfe vier
rückschluss zwei plünderungen zwei
freunde ich liebe euch was das denn ist
aber nur zeichen oder freunde ich meine
bzw hoffe das ist das was mit den ganzen
schildern steht aber noch ein schild für
saft damals aber das kann jetzt
eigentlich auch mal abbauen ist zwar
sein grundstück aber das ist ein
bisschen unnötig dass ich das eigentlich
damals hin geschrieben habe ich verstehe
ehrlich gesagt nicht dass hier so aber
es ist geil das ist geil das hier so
balken sind und so dass getragen wird
dass es noch nicht so fertig ist also
das sieht sehr cool aus werde ich mich
demnächst auch mal am bau beteiligen ich
warte jetzt einfach wenig zeit wegen
geburtstag uni klausurphase blablabla
mit aufnehmen und so weiter und so fort
aber es wird auf jeden fall in zukunft
diese tropfen der baum
die so tropft der baum degert komisch
ist das denn ist da oben irgendwo wasser
oder regnet wahrscheinlich ja es regte
nahezu immer auf diesem server eltern
plan wieso hier also ich habe auf jeden
fall vorgenommen in zukunft mehr
minecraft leben hochzuladen ich hab das
herzen erst so alle zwei tage gemacht
und jetzt in letzter zeit einfach gar
nicht mehr weil einfach dieses ganze
role play ist ein bisschen an mir
vorbeigezogen also wir haben natürlich
die handwerks jährige gründer die türen
sekte und jetzt stehen wir auf einmal so
schilder vor der tür das ich leiden
werde oder so aber das hat mich bisher
halt eigentlich nicht so beeindruckt
aber ich hatte auch einfach wenig zeit
und ich möchte mich demnächst auf jeden
fall immer kraft leben ein wenig mehr
nicht nicht integrieren integrieren hat
irgendwie falsch aber ich möchte auf
jeden fall mehr hochladen davon weil ich
finde mein schafft leben ist das
perfekte projekt um einfach ein paar
fragen zu beantworten das möchte in
dieser folge auch machen was ist denn
hier ist richtig viel passiert alter
hier ist ja richtig viel einfach gebaut
worden das ist mir da hinten grad schon
aufgefallen als der roller schiffes
wieder da bist ja noch irgendwie was das
sieht aber alles mega cool aus immer so
mit ihm mit dem wasser auf dem boden und
so schon ganz neues pracht mehr das netz
ok
ich schaue mal eben ob man da hinten die
farm welt kann weil ich möchte auf jeden
fall sondern so ein bisschen fahren wo
wo kann ich denn hier in die farm
weltalter deshalb trat ein bisschen
crazy wie kann ich denn hier irgendwie
sind jüngst drei leute einfach nur für
server die wie kann ich denn hier eine
farm welt ist sie nicht irgendwo war
hier nicht mal so ein schild oder so wer
möchte helfen gesucht eisen steigen
reisende in ear to hell wie kann das
denn sein
die farbenwelt wir lassen uns nicht von
den psychospielchen beeindrucken
gemeinsam sind wir stark bürger der
stadt bleibe lara wo ist denn die farm
welt ich kriege ja gar nichts mehr mit
ihr sehr wichtig crazy wieso wo ist denn
die farm welt die fachwelt ist einfach
weg oder bin ich einfach am arsch und
kann ihn nicht finden irgendwie keine
ahnung aber ist auch egal dann werden
wir heute auf jeden fall so ein bisschen
jetzt bei mir im haus weiter bauen und
ein paar fragen beantworten ich werde es
nämlich dar und jetzt einfach mal aus
höhlen und da jetzt irgendwas hinsetzen
also ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht genau
wie ich den das orbiting weiterbauen
soll ich wäre da wahrscheinlich ja wie
schon vorher gemacht habe
ankara ist einfach ein beispiel nehmen
wie der sein haus da gebaut hat aber ich
habe auch lust ein paar eigene elemente
reinzubringen wenn ihr ideen habt könnt
ihr die gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
aber ich habe auch bei twitter gefragt
herr staeck fragt luca stellt mir doch
mal ein paar hübsche fragten ob wir da
ein paar fragen bitte und dann habe ich
einfach tweetdeck nebenbei aufgemacht
und die fragen kommen eingeprasselt
wegen regen alter
ich hoffe ich kriegte einfach mal ein
paar fragen jetzt raus magst du
rolltreppen
ich finde immer mehr als wenn ich im
supermarkt reingehe oder rolltreppen
sind beziehungsweise nicht im supermarkt
sondern irgendein kaufhaus oder so bei
rolltreppen sind einfach so ein moment
der stille kannst du einfach stehen und
die treppe machten refn dunkeln stehen
bleiben
fragt mich nicht was ich genommen habe
das ist ich kann was mit mir los welche
specialist frage ich wieder weg aber ich
glaube welche special gibt es für
400.000 von enten übrigens dank an 7.000
abonnenten
aber jeder der mich schon länger kennt
weiß eigentlich dass ich so selten
specials mache weil einfach
ich finde so werden also richtige
lightning bugs ich finde halt so jede
zahl ist es ist egal welche zahl das ist
auch egal ob man jetzt 20 wird oder ob
man alleine 20 wird oder was lästig wie
alt weil es ist ich verstehe es einfach
nicht es kommen neue abonnenten dazu man
könnte rein theoretisch jede zahl
einfach jede abonnentenzahl könnte man
zelebrieren und sagen danke für den
neuen abonnenten und so deswegen ich bin
euch natürlich dankbar dass sie mich
alle so viel abonniert das finde ich
extrem cool aber es ist halt einfach
jetzt nichts wo ich sage war unfassbar
geil oder so wenn jeden tag kommen
kommen mehrere leute dazu ich bin euch
natürlich sehr dankbar
das soll jetzt auch nicht arrogant
wirken oder so aber ich bin einfach
nicht so der specials mensch weil ich
einfach findet das kann sonst wenn man
special macht einer bestimmten zahl dann
ist es halt einfach so wie wenn man
keine ahnung wann man könnte bei jeder
falschen mann deswegen kommt
wahrscheinlich ein special
welche youtuber kooks und einer freizeit
doppelpunkt dnk c rike fragt das ist ja
bei den damen hier vorlesen in meiner
freizeit schaue ich derzeit nahezu gar
keine youtube schau letzten drei
wirklich als aktiver zuschauer bei
letzterer extrem cool ist ich finde das
format geil ich respektiere die arbeit
die im schnitt steckt also ich bearbeite
ja selber meine videos mal so ein
bisschen in letzter zeit nicht so viel
also effektiv schonend weil das so
serien sind wo man bearbeiten muss weil
man sachen vorstellt und zwei transport
aber so minecraft leben einfach nur ein
paar kap setzen und so aber deswegen
kennt man halt genau was was die da halt
genauso einfach und eine arbeit leisten
für dieses letzte und weil ich einfach
respekt vor den leuten aber die korrekt
drauf sind auch so mal feiern gehen am
wochenende und so weiter und so fort
coole jungs einfach deswegen schaue ich
eigentlich zur zeit nur träumen
hast du mal jemandem abonniert okay das
eine blöde frage wie häufig vorgelesen
wie stehst du zum spiele meister ich
habe bei twitter gepostet ich bin der
spieler meist aber einfach nur
verwirrung zu stiften und ich bin das
nicht an alle die das irgendwie denken
oder so jetzt
ich glaube auch nächstes grad nachts
deswegen ist es hier so dunkel
ich möchte jetzt auch nicht fragen ob
wir mal schlafen gehen weil die
wahrscheinlich gerade alle arbeiten sind
oder so hier
ich bin nicht der spieler meister aber
ich bin auf jeden fall so weit in der
story drin von bergmann die lakers und
so weiter die das ganze ja so machen und
so weiter das ich weiß wer der spiele
meister ist zumindest was er tat was er
tut und wer vor dem jetzt nicht denken
weil ich dort leben hochladen dass ich
nicht den ganzen tag und ich werde
wahrscheinlich bald auch mal so ein paar
kurzfilme einfach machen also der das
hab ich ja damals schon mal gemacht ganz
damals von einem jahr oder vor zwei
jahren habe ich auch so kleine kurzfilme
man minecraft gemacht freunde
wer war das
wer
das alter pacers das wird auf meinem
grundstück was hat er von komischen kopf
was ist mit dir oder was ist was ist los
wie so was was soll das das ist denn los
mit diesem projekt alter alle sind
negativ und boxen und kommen an und ich
habe mich einfach komplett verlaufen
ich habe überhaupt keinen plan wo ich
bin gerade das ist doch wo bin ich denn
lange laufen dass ich jetzt hier so
komisch wieder am arsch der b8 ich glaub
ich bin bei pixel x würde
keine ahnung was hier los ist
einer hat gibt schröder dass sie meinem
einkommen pulli anhat
das ist cool ich bin zurzeit aber
überlegen ob ich mit mit max zusammen
und vielleicht noch anders oder so mal
schauen sondern auch seinen sohn so
einen pulli design oder shirt design
haltmache was man ganz cool sind weil
max design jahr vom design her zumindest
so ähnlich ist wie mainz mainz so
ähnlich wie max also einfach sondern
schriftzug einer coolen formen sind
gerade mal überlegen ob das irgendwie
cool wäre oder so aber mal schauen
dieses ganze noch entwickelt ich
beantworte ich noch ein paar fragen und
fülle noch so ein bisschen das ding
daraus wenn ihr irgendwelche anregungen
habt was ich eventuell den nächsten
folge mal machen soll eventuell ob ich
auch mal so ein bisschen mit role play
anfangen soll oder ob ich auch mal so
kleine kurzfilme vor jeder folge machen
soll dass man mittlerweile nahezu alle
vor jeder folge noch seinen kleinen
kurzfilm oder so dann würde ich mich
freuen wenn ihr mir das mal die
kommentare schreiben
und da will ich sagen beantworten drei
fragen drei coole fragen ein jahr lang
kein internet oder einen monat nicht
pushen
auf jeden fall ein monat nicht duschen
das ist doch keine frage alter schaust
du dir englische let's play sun
englische nicht aber amerikanische
teilweise also ich finde es bei captain
sparks manchmal echt mega informativ was
leider auch filmore beck spielt und so
finde ich selber ganz interessant und
ich schon wieder eine tür gehört alter
also wenn schon nur käpt'n sparkurs aber
jetzt nicht so steil dass minecraft der
norm rumschreien ist oder so was
aber englischen nahezu nicht ich kenne
jetzt auch glaube ich gar keine
englischen let's play außerhalb luxus
oder wie die heißen da oder herzlichen
glückwunsch für 7.000 abonnenten
dankeschön hat sich richtung geburtstag
dankeschön
was würdest du tun wenn du kein youtube
hätte ist wahrscheinlich genau das
gleiche wie jetzt auch also ein fach
studieren oder würde ich mir geld und so
neben anders herr verdient und hätte
andere hobbys die mir spaß machen würden
wäre wahrscheinlich auch noch im
fußballverein und so weiter und so fort
was kommen sonst noch so für fragen wenn
du unsterblich wärs und alle personen
wählen müsstest die mit dir die das mit
ihr wäre wer wäre diese person
eigentlich mein bester kumpel aber den
kennt ihr nicht
deswegen würde ich einfach sagen oder
nur ich gute freundin von mir auch aber
die kann ja auch nicht deswegen einfach
wenn von den personen die ihr kennt
teilte hat das schild stand der vorhin
noch nicht was ist los mit diesem
projekt und da steht einfach so ein
fucking tnt vor meiner tür und jetzt
kommen hier pfeil runter geschossen was
ist los nee freunde ich disconnect jetzt
ich gehe raus ich mach das nicht mehr
das kann ja nicht sein ich wollte
eigentlich fragen beantworten aber nö
ich protestiere jetzt mit scheiß laden
hier
ich akzeptiere das nicht das kann nicht
sein dass in diesem projekt es läuft
alles schief
das projekt heißt minecraft leben und
nicht minecraft hassen ich lebte das
spiel wären an handelt oder möchten los
mit den wenn es euch gefallen habe ich
mich über die bewertung freuen und wir
sehen uns eventuell in einem nächsten
video von minecraft leben wieder wenn
ihr einen plan habe was ich machen soll
auch sei
dann schreibt sie die kommentare sie nun
zum nächsten mal wieder typisch ich
sollte das echt mal lassen dass ich die
fans gerne mal runter schmeiße alter das
ist ein mega blöde angewohnheit gegen
die halterung ist kaputt oder ich glaube
dass das nur bla bla bla bla bla